[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je dis 9 mai bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal de tv 78 c'est le
tour d'horizon de l'actualité locale et
régionale tout de suite les titres de
cette édition
souhaitez-vous le maintien de la prison
en centre ville c'est la question posée
par poissy à ses habitants la ville va
lancer une consultation citoyenne sur la
maison centrale du 1er au 16 juin fin
mars une partie du mur d'enceinte
extérieur s'effondrait relançant le
débat sur la vétusté du site
c'était une promesse du maire didier
fischer lors de son élection à
coignières créer des conseils de
quartier des espaces de discussion pour
les administrés afin de s'exprimer sur
des sujets du quotidien dans la commune
mardi soir une deuxième réunion se
tenait à la maison de voisinage
enfin le libre est proposée par le
service patrimoine et inventaires de la
région ile-de-france son titre le
patrimoine de mantes-la-jolie un passé
en éternel devenir 160 pages pour
connaître les richesses de la ville du
nord des yvelines ses fortifications son
hôte yens son hôtel duo encore sa
collégiale gothique reportages et
invités dans ce journal
et puis nous parlerons en plateau de la
jolie soirée cinéma au programme demain
soir c'est au grenier à sel à trappes et
les images d'abord de cette cérémonie ce
matin à versailles le préfet
jean-jacques brot a présidé l'hommage
aux policiers morts en service en
présence du président du sénat gérard
larcher et de la procureure de la
république de versailles
le préfet a profité de la cérémonie pour
récompenser carla une chaîne de l'unité
cynophile
elle a reçu la médaille pour acte de
courage et de dévouement direction
poissy souvenez vous le 28 mars dernier
un mur d'enceinte de la prison s'était
écroulé en réponse à cet incident le
maire karl olive a lancé une
consultation citoyenne question le
déplacement ou non de la maison centrale
en dehors du centre-ville les précisions
de mickael miro la prison de poissy sera
t-elle déplacer une consultation
citoyenne numérique va être lancée le
samedi 1er juin par la mairie pour
connaître l'avis des habitants une
décision qui fait écho à l'effondrement
survenu le 28 mars dernier d'une partie
du mur d'enceinte de la prison notre
prison est édifié ici depuis 18 ans 21
ça fait presque 200 ans et je ne parle
même pas auparavant avec le couvent des
ursulines dans les années 16 150 elle a
l'âge de ses artères et elle est de plus
en plus dangereuse pour les administrés
ne sont pas l'abri d'un mur qui
s'écroule
nous souhaitons aller plus loin je
souhaite consulter les pisciacais pour
savoir si comme nous ils souhaitent ou
non le maintien de la maison centrale en
centre ville pour donner leur avis les
habitants de la commune devront
télécharger une application sur leur
smartphone ou leur tablette
le dispositif sera également accessible
dans les maisons de quartier le vote
sera quant à lui anonyme est unique on y
aura trois réponses possibles
oui non ou votes blancs et nous avons
fait appel à un organisme sécurisé
proposé par notre parrot partenaires
orange pour pouvoir rassembler
l'ensemble des vols en toute
confidentialité est qu une personne qui
puisse voter à la fois évidemment les
résultats seront dévoilés le dimanche
s'est joint à partir de 11 heures en
mairie sont transmis au ministère de la
justice gestionnaire de la prison il est
évident que si les pisciacais et les
pisciacais aller dans le sens d'un nom
maintient donc d'un transfert de la
prison ailleurs que dans centre ville ça
ne donnerait plus de poids et je veux
pas dire de pression mais plus de poids
plus d'arguments encore pour valider ce
que nous souhaitons depuis des années
ici impossible selon l'élu le
déplacement de la prison sur un autre
secteur de la ville coûterait près de 80
millions d'euros contre 60 millions pour
une rénovation promise par l'état pour
la remplacer différents projets sont à
l'étude comme un musée ou des espaces
verts toujours à poissy la visite mardi
de franck riester le ministre de la
culture est venu inaugurer le musée du
jouet il ouvre officiellement public ce
week end après trois ans de travaux créé
en 1976 le lieu possède une collection
de 14 mille objets datant des 19e et 20e
siècles les façades la toiture et
l'intérieur du musée ont été rénovés
coût du chantier 3 millions d'euros
financés notamment par l'état et le
département des yvelines
c'est une nouvelle institution à
coignières les conseils de quartier la
commune a été dit
et en quatre secteurs le 16 avril
dernier une cinquantaine d'habitants a
participé à la première réunion et ce
mardi un deuxième rendez-vous s'est
tenue à proximité de la résidence des
acacias le reportage de nicolas landry
faire participer les habitants à la
politique de la commune c'est l'objectif
de ces conseils de quartier poser des
questions proposer des idées donner son
avis les cogner rien sont invités à
s'exprimer sur tous les sujets
concernant leur quartier c'était
l'occasion de poser les questions en
direct au maire de parler des sujets qui
nous préoccupent en tant que citoyens
ils échangent et parler des problèmes
font avancer
non c'est l'état du quartier les
conseils de quartier une promesse de
campagne de didier fischer mise en place
depuis son élection le maire a décidé
d'accorder une enveloppe de 30 mille
euros pour concrétiser les projets
proposés
ça peut être un aménagement j'ai pas de
passage pour piétons ça peut être un
aménagement des bacs à fleurs ça peut
être de l'éclairage voyez il ya ça peut
être tout d'une certaine façon on est
pour l'instant rien n'est défini un et
c'est en fonction des besoins en effet
du quartier c'est essentiellement un
rôle d'écouté
c'est une première prise de parole
c'était la première premier conseil de
quartier sur ce secteur donc c'est une
découverte pour tout le monde
je pense que le prochain sera un petit
peu plus aboutie et qu'on pourra
apporter vraiment des réponses aux
poignets rien coignard est découpé en
quatre quartiers les réunions seront
prévues chaque trimestre elles feront
l'objet d'un compte-rendu mise en ligne
sur le site de la ville
elle a été lancé officiellement
aujourd'hui par la région ile de france
la plateforme kg aux outils gratuits
accessibles en ligne ou via votre
smartphone pour tous les franciliens de
plus de 15 ans qu'ils vous permet
d'apprendre ou de perfectionner votre
anglais votre allemand votre espagnol
pour ce faire l'application propose et
1500 contenu multimédia extraits de
films de séries télé ou encore de clips
musicaux
l'objectif pour la collectivité faire de
l'île de france une région multilingue
l'ile-de-france toujours mais cette fois
ci par le biais de son service
patrimoine et inventaire qui publie ce
livre le patrimoine de mantes-la-jolie
un passé en éternel devenir c'est aux
éditions lieu-dit 160 pages illustrées
sur le patrimoine et d'histoire de la
ville yvelinoise et c'est un livre
préparé sous votre direction jeudi
corteville bonsoir en soit vous êtes la
cheffe du service patrimoine et
inventaires de la région ile-de-france
alors avant de parler de l' ouvrage vous
propose de regarder à ce reportage l'un
des lieux phares de mantes-la-jolie
c'est bien sûr sa collégiale gothique
petite soeur de notre dame de paris par
son aspect elle a été érigée au 12e
siècle et l'édifice a vu passer des
personnalités telles que lé roi saint
louis philippe auguste ou plus récemment
le général de gaulle regardez ce
reportage de michael et demi d'euros
elle fascine depuis neuf siècles
l'aimanté la collégiale notre dame à
l'origine lieu de prière pour les
chanoines a été construite vers
1150 l'édifice disposer trois portails
ainsi que de deux tours de 55 mètres de
haut ce qui lui vaut le surnom de petite
soeur de notre dame de paris
elle ressemble à notre dame elle s'est
aussi inspiré d'autres d'autres
cathédrales comme son lit sous laon
malgré tout c'est vrai qu on peut penser
que après la réussite de notre dame de
paris puisque celle ci a été construite
un peu après sans doute at-on repris
certains éléments à l'intérieur des
vitraux rendent hommage aux
personnalités passées par le lieu de
culte saint louis ou encore philippe
auguste mais pour contempler l'un des
trésors de la collégiale il faut prendre
un peu de hauteur
comme c'est bon en fait trop tard
une rose à s'installer au xiiie siècle
reposante sur 8 mètres cinquante de
diamètre le jugement dernier
on a la chance d'avoir conservé ya pas
beaucoup de vitraux qui ont été
conservée intégralement
elle a été restaurée elle a été
restaurée très vite il semble que même
saint-louis donné de l'argent dans les
années 247 pour restaurer la rosace mais
on a quand même là un certain nombre de
panneaux d'origine presque tous témoins
de l'histoire la collégiale a traversé
le temps et l'histoire de france malgré
les bombardements des américains le 30
mai 1944 lors de la seconde guerre
mondiale l'édifice a survécu pendant la
révolution française les murs extérieurs
ont également été en partie dégrader les
révolutionnaires s'en sont pris aux
portails avec évidemment toutes les
statues qui représentait bas des figures
du mal je vais passer sur les détails
mais on a vu comment certaines têtes
étaient littéralement décapiter ses les
révolutionnaires font qu'on sent
absolument le lieu laisse également
place à de nombreux fantasmes selon la
légende le coeur du roi de france
philippe auguste mort le 14 juillet 1224
amendes seraient toujours présents dans
le choeur de la collégiale
une théorie non validé à ce jour plus
récemment c'est la toiture et ses formes
géométriques qui interroge les passants
donc on a mis un tas d'histoires
pourquoi la collégiale la banque
n'at-elle pas souffert des bombardements
allemands jamais été bombardé par les
allemands évidemment et bien parce qu'il
y avait des croix gammées sur le saas
est décédé sornettes
si vous regardez bien écrit pas de croix
gammées mais plutôt de croix contre
potence et qui rappelle
les armes de type no sag de champagne
lequel aurait il semble qu'ils financent
et la toiture des histoires et des
trésors qui attire plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de touristes chaque année dans
cette collégiale classé monument
historique depuis 1840 à la collégiale
et bien d'autres choses à voir à
mantes-la-jolie ce livre le patrimoine
de mantes-la-jolie un passé en éternel
devenir dresse l'inventaire justement de
ce patrimoine les textes sont signés de
roselyne bussières et je rappelle que c
est un ouvrage sous votre direction 1
julie corteville pourquoi choisir de
traiter la ville de mantes la jolie
comme sujet l'inventaire du patrimoine
qui a été créée en 80 s'intéresse aux
grandes villes aux villes moyennes
l'ile-de-france qui structurent vraiment
le territoire c'est à dire quand on
pense au patrimoine d'île de france
on pense spontanément aux grands moments
chocs d'axa exception or le patrimoine
ile de france réside vraiment
essentiellement dans ces villes moyennes
qui à la fois sont représentatives de
l'histoire d'île de france on a vu que
la grande histoire nationale s'était
déroulée aussi amont des grand faits
historiques pour pour la france et en
même temps ce sont des palissades
architecture c'est à dire qu'on peut y
lire toutes les étapes historiques
majeurs de la construction l'île de
france et par conséquent toutes les
étapes de l'architecturé
mais justement alors pourquoi s'il ville
intéressante en terme d'histoire de
patrimoine finalement quels sont les
sites remarquables à mantes la jolie
mais elle est fabuleuse parce que elle a
une histoire très longue
ouvrage qui est ici il ya beaucoup
d'ouvragés déjà décrit surmontable je
pense que l'apport de cet ouvrage de
roselyne du sierre et de laurenque
l'usic pour les photos et qu'il fait à
la fois une synthèse condom comme je
parle de paname ça c'est que il déroule
depuis gaza depuis la chapelle de
gastien cours au 12e jusqu'au val fourré
aujourd'hui toutes les étapes et on
laborde vraiment en termes de patrimoine
parce que on essaye de comprendre
comment tu comment évolue ce territoire
et que l'état du patrimoine du plus
ancien au plus contemporain
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs s'est dit sur la
quatrième de couverture c'est finalement
difficile de voir une logique à travers
tout ce patrimoine vous le dit un
patrimoine médiéval est aujourd'hui le
grand ensemble du val fourré c'est aussi
ça l'objectif de l'ouvragé s'est donné
une logique finalement c'est cette
pédagogie de l'histoire sans raccourci
sans idées reçues c'est vrai que si on
dit manteau aujourd'hui on pense soit
collégial soit val fourré et en fait que
fait apparaître cet ouvrage c'est toute
la densité du patrimoine qui se limite
pas ses deux extrémités on a inventé on
le voit dans le virage de roselyne
bussières a grâce aux photos de laurent
des hôtels particuliers des maisons de
bourg des cités jardins et puis il faut
pas oublier que manque c'est aussi un
exemple en ile-de-france de modernité on
a des couples assez fascinant mère
architectes qui vont complètement faire
l'entraînement dans lés 20e siècle je
pense notamment à raymond barrable
marabout qui va être le grand architecte
de l'entre-deux-guerres puis raymond
lopez qui va amener toute la modernité
amante qui va aller jusqu'au val fourré
mais il faut imaginer que ces modèles
urbains que ces deux architectes
urbanistes on concevoir pour mantes sont
en france à ce moment là complètement
novateur et le titre impasse en éternel
devenir pourquoi le que je vous sais
évidemment il ya un lien entre le passé
la modernité absolument c'est guinée
dubalen cest et c'est l'idée de aussi de
ce travail de terrain qu'on a conduit
avec le sérieux des yvelines et hélène
buisson pendant quatre années en
associant la population parce que l'on
parle du patrimoine on a l'impression
qu'on est uniquement dans l'histoire et
l'histoire de l'art
c'est un travail qui a été mené de façon
très étroite avec les habitants les
lycéens qui ont fait visiter leur ville
et ya on le voit et c'est ouvragé répond
arrêt est l'attachement des habitants à
ce patrimoine mais dont ils connaissent
en général que quelques facettes
mais qu'est ce qu'on y trouve dans ce
livre du texte de la photo c'est un beau
coup de photos
avec des photos assez inédite de la
collégiale et puis ces photos qui font
découvrir aussi la beauté de ses hôtels
particuliers qu'on ne voit plus voilà
donc c'est vraiment redécouvrir ce
patrimoine dans une logique scientifique
très ouverte accessible à tous qui
redonne les logiques sur le temps long
du développement de ce territoire est un
ouvrage de ce type
combien de temps ça nécessite pour le
préparer combien de personnes ont
travaillé sur cet ouvrage alors de
nombreuses personnes il ya plusieurs
auteurs la conservatrice du musée
la responsable du département du
patrimoine je vous ai dit de saluer des
yvelines qui a arpenté avec une autre
chercheuse chaque parcelle
chaque rue pour hiérarchiser les
éléments de patrimoine
évidemment laurent cru site qui est à
nos photographes qui a passé beaucoup de
temps justement pour essayer de montrer
un patrimoine sous un jour différent
on a par exemple de la façade de la
collégiale c'est un travail de montage
et de prise de vue qui a pris un temps
infini la couverture avec cette façon de
le clézio effectivement et qui en montre
vraiment toute la majesté et là et la
même mentalité
donc oui c'est vraiment un travail très
large en associant toutes les forces
vives de la commune de la mairie un
travail étroit avec les équipes
municipales et on est aussi très fier de
ça parce que l'inventaire c'est très
important pour connaître le patrimoine
mais n'est la meilleure protection du
patrimoine vous savez ce sont les
habitants et donc sensibiliser et
travailler avec les habitants
c'est extrêmement extrêmement important
un mot juste pour terminer sur le
service patrimoine et inventeur de la
région ile de france quelles sont ses
missions à ce service ont des missions
qui ont été définis par malraux en 64
c'est recenser toutes les richesses
patrimoniales d'un territoire et c'est
un outil méthodologique unique
disques en france c'est arpenter le
territoire par c'est la parcelle rue la
rue alors c'est très long ensuite on
repart on prend en photo on confronte
avec les archives avec les plans donc
c'est un travail extrêmement rigoureux
extrêmement long mais qui permet
aujourd'hui en france d'avoir ce
gisement patrimoniale extraordinaire et
cette connaissance du patrimoine dont on
parle tant aujourd'hui est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres projets en préparation
bien sûr le patrimoine de l'île de
france c'est beaucoup de choses très
différentes
l'aéroport d'orly vitrine de la
modernité des sixties mais les théâtre
art déco d'ile-de-france mais les fermes
fortifiées
enfin vous voyez on peut vraiment toute
la palette du patrimoine francilien
et je rappelle ce livre le patrimoine de
mantes-la-jolie un passé en éternel
devenir c'est disponible aux éditions
lieu-dit au prix de 24 euros merci julie
cortenais s'il est repassé en plateau
chef du service patrimoine et
inventaires de la région ile de france
un autre patrimoine qui a été longuement
chantier permanent c'est le château de
versailles de nombreux projets ont été
pensées du règne de louis xiv à l'
empire et pour la première fois ces
réflexions sont présentés au public une
exposition est organisée dans le cadre
de la biennale d'architecturé de paysage
du paysage d'île de france c'est en ce
moment dans la cité royale mélanie poker
et c'est un petit bout d'un grand projet
l'ale gabriel est construite en 1771
pensé par ange jacques gabriel aussi
créateur de l'opéra royal
l'architecte propose pendant 25 ans des
projets au roi mais son projet était
beaucoup plus ambitieux il s'agissait de
reconstruire totalement le coeur du
château de versailles
supprimer tout ce qui pouvait rappeler
le premier château le château briques et
pierres de louis xiv pour donner une
harmonie à la façade un chantier stoppé
par la mort de louis 15 en 1774 comme ce
grand projet l'exposition architecture
rêver révèle les idées qui n'ont jamais
été réalisé le château a servi de lieu
d'inspiration du xviie jusqu'à l' empire
le dessin architecture peut être du très
beau dessin c'est aussi l'un des
objectifs de l'exposition c'est de
montrer finalement ces dessins qui sont
souvent peu connus qui sont exploitées
par les historiens pour leurs intérêts
on va dire historique intellectuelle
mais qui ne sont pas montrés finalement
pour eux mêmes pour leurs qualités
esthétiques
près de 120 dessins sont rassemblés des
dessins d'architecturé des plans des
projets parfois ambitieux comme cette
utopie détiennent où il voulait
architecte du xviiie siècle
son projet est véritablement d'avancé
considérablement la façade est de
supprimer tout ce qui
visuellement bloc cette vue sur la
façade
il élargit considérablement l'avant
cours il supprime les ailes des
ministres l'un des projets les plus
grandioses estimé alors à près de 14
millions de livres des utopies et des
réalités qui donne un autre regard sur
le palais et on parle de cet événement
pour refermer ce journal une jolie
soirée cinéma se déroule demain c'est au
grenier à sel à trappes à partir de
20h30 un rendez vous pour mettre en
avant des courts métrages locaux et pour
en parler et julien dénervaud bonsoir
mon sort vous êtes le vice président et
directeur artistique de jolis prod c'est
une association qui propose cette soirée
alors jolie prod a été créée en novembre
2018 c'est ça quels sont ses objectifs
les objectifs de jolis prod c'est de
créer des projets artistiques d'en
développer de les accompagner tout en
mettant en fait en relation des amateurs
et des professionnels pour promouvoir la
culture locale puis quels types de
projets ont déjà pu être développée
essentiellement des courts métrages
parce qu'on est tous issus du cinéma
donc le président de l'association
olivier salazar avec qui j'ai créé ça on
a essentiellement fait des courts
métrages mais sinon on se destine aussi
à faire des concerts du théâtre ya plein
de choses qui se mettent en place dans
cette jolie soirée cinéma qui arrive
demain soir il n'aura l'occasion de
parler des autres concepts plus tard
alors pour mettre en avant justement ces
talents locaux les jolies soirées ça
c'est un concept qui a été lancée par
l'association la première c'est demain
excès de jolies soirées cinéma le
concept global de ces jolies soirées
c'est quoi le concept des jolies soirées
c'est de mettre en avant des talents
locaux
parce que le territoire est
l'un déborde de talent d'énergie et
c'est donc l'idée c'est de mettre en
avant ses talents de promouvoir les
lieux de culture locaux selon donc
mettre en avant si ces lieux ici le
cinéma le grenier à sel demain soir et
en même temps créer du lien entre ces
lieux
les artistes mais aussi entre le public
et les habitants enfin entre le les
artistes le public pardon voilà de créer
du lien entre tout le monde créer des
synergies et mettre en compétences et en
réseau des gens c'est important de créer
ces synergies vous le disiez ça un
bassin qui regorge de talents il faut
les aider ses talents il faut les aider
et je pense que c'est important de
mettre en avant des choses qui le sont
peu voilà parce que du talent il y en a
pas que sur les trucs nationaux
médiatisé énormément voilà il y en a
aussi chez nous et c'est les lieux sont
ouverts à notre disposition jusqu'au pas
de nos portes et pas besoin de remonter
sur paris à la capitale ou autres dans
des grandes salles
ici il ya des superbes salles qui
proposent des événements et je pense que
c'est important d'aller découvrir des
talents d'ici et c'est ça mais comme
cette salle du grenier à sel à trappes
qui est un cinéma avec cette jolie
soirée cinéma c'est demain donc vendredi
à 20h30 le concept là pour le coup on
veut être sûr sur du film sur du court
métrage
là on est sur une projection de courts
métrages avec dix réalisateurs qui
viennent du coin donc de trappes et des
environs de trappes
on a été énormément soutenu par la ville
de trappes et par le grenier à sel pour
organiser cette soirée d'ailleurs au
passage les remercie et voilà le concept
c de projeter des films et d'échanger
avec les réalisateurs c'est à dire que
vous venez vous essayer dans la salle
voyez un film c'est des courts métrages
forcément vous allez avoir des des
questions et vous verrez tout de suite
posé les questions au réalisateur aux
acteurs parce que les équipes des films
seront présents demain soir dans la
salle du grenier à sel donc l'idée c'est
d'échanger tous ensemble et de montrer
un peu ce qui se fait localement mais
vous le disais c'est des réalisateurs
qui viennent des environs de saint
quentin en yvelines de trappes
c'est ça c'est ça tout à fait donc deux
trappes de saint quentin en yvelines
environ villepreux guyancourt montigny
elancourt un petit peu de toute
l'agglomération
beaucoup de trappes aussi puisqu'on a
fait un appel à projets sur trappe et
ensuite l'idée c'est
c'est ce que je disais c'est d'échanger
avec eux et vous allez voir qu'il est
quand même des films des jeunes film des
réalisateurs très très jeunes qui ont
leur premier film et des films plutôt
semi-professionnels qu'ont déjà remporté
des prix dans des festivals
voilà donc pareil les réalisateurs vont
se rencontrer entre eux et peut-être
créer des projets ensemble plus tard
mais quel type de courts métrages on
pourra voir demain quel sens tout alors
vous dire mais quel sujet par exemple ça
peut traiter
il ya deux il ya de tout sujet ça va
être aussi bien dramatique que de la
comédie on va toucher des sujets plus
sensibles puisque d'autres plus que par
exemple sur les violences conjugales ou
sur sur les sur les meurtres comme on
peut y avoir des trucs sur l'homophobie
ou autre il ya plusieurs choses je peux
pas te dire un niveau et devenir devenir
pour il ya des surprises forcément et
vous le disiez ça c'est important qu'il
y ait des courts métrages semi
professionnels des des courts métrages
un peu plus amateur ça c'est aussi une
volonté de l'intérêt sportif de la jolie
soirée c'est à dire que oui on va
montrer au public des talents locaux
mais sait aussi que les talents entre
cuisse et bien profiter des expériences
des uns et des autres pour pouvoir
ensuite se créent leur propre réseau
professionnel pour pouvoir avancer
pour y assister à la soirée ce qu'il
faut s'inscrire au préalable non il ya
un événement sur la page facebook de
deux jolies prod vous pouvez y aller
pour avoir toutes les informations ci
s'affiche enfin la page facebook
voilà le site est en cours de création
s'excuse et sinon vous venez avec le
plus de personnes possible on a que 200
places donc ramené pas non plus 500
personnes mais vous pouvez venir au
moins 15 à 20 il n'y a pas de société ce
qui est un prix d'entrée alors les
tarifs sont des tarifs du grenier à sel
il faut aller sur le site le grenier à
sel point com et vous aurez tous les
tarifs et quels sont les autres soirées
en préparation donc là on aura une
première soirée cinéma les les autres
soirées en préparation alors il ya une
soirée concert je peux pas encore le
dire ça va être ça arrive ça sera une
jolie soirée concert dans
l'agglomération si avec des gouttes
locaux également forcément dans une des
salles de l'agglomération je peux pas
vous dire laquelle
mais ça sera en septembre donc quand on
se tient informé sur la page facebook de
cette jolie prod merci julien dénervaud
merci d'être passé en plateau vice
président et directeur artistique
de cette association et je rappelle ce
rendez vous la joie lui la jolie soirée
cinéma au programme demain au grenier à
sel à trappes à partir de 20h30 voilà
c'est la fin de cette édition le 7-8
journal c'est à consulter également sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile et dans un instant au maryland à
iapichino vous donne quelques idées de
sorties dans son émission le 7-8 loisirs
quant à moi et je vous retrouve dès
lundi pour une nouvelle édition
d'information locale belle soirée sur tv
[Musique]